what's your advice to live a happy life
um this is my advice
the next kids ain't nothing that I went
through because they don't know nothing
that I went through I am who I am and
I'm an NYC person that's it you can't
judge me
[Music]
welcome to hey babe look at this we
don't have a song today sorry about that
we also don't have Sal so instead we
were looking for a guest and I said you
know who's going to be the guest the
homeless pimp
we know you never thought because you
know there's always a thing when when
you know when Sal is out or when any of
the co-hosts are out you're like oh who
do we have to get to replace him can we
get this comic or this act or this I
said you know what we're not doing any
of that we're not doing any of that
we're getting homeless pimp
we're getting
you know
um it's just like getting Joaquin
Phoenix from The Joker it's literally
it's it's literally instead of the Joker
we got the smoker
that's that's who it is homeless pimp
the smoker first of all the fans want to
know what's your real name
uh Mike Mike because a lot of people
don't know somebody came rather pimp I'd
rather rather pimp yeah somebody came to
my show last week I forget where I was
oh for in uh in uh Montclair New Jersey
shout out to Wellmont Theater excellent
theater excellent Town Montclair New
Jersey high taxes excellent Town
um
and they were the girl was dressed as
you oh yeah I saw that on Instagram and
then she gave me coffee from her
family's Coffee Company yeah and and and
Jasmine
um and and we were gonna drink it but
Jasmine's like I don't know because I
believe the coffee company she told me
the coffee company but she was like but
she gave it to us in a bag that was
taped with Scotch tape so jazz is like
yeah but how do you know that she
doesn't want to poison you and I was
like I don't think she does and she's
like how do you know I'm like because I
just there's no I don't think she wants
to poison me I said I think maybe she
wants a poison pimp
now would you would you drink random
coffee I don't know in a scotch tape bag
because the hey babe fans are are sweet
and the chaos fans are sweet maybe but I
don't this is new to me famous people
get food all the time from strangers and
I'm gonna drink the coffee I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna drink the coffee well
you're gonna drink the coffee but did
you search your kids Halloween candy for
Fentanyl
well no because I only allowed my kids
to have candy that was wrapped but I
have you know this my security camera we
had taken our kids to another
neighborhood to trick or treat and we
had a bowl of candy out you know just
left it open like kind of a self-serve
and some group of teenagers came up and
we heard them on the camera they go they
looked at the candy they go this house
[ __ ] sucks
and I was like good for those kids
um I but but but has your house gotten
toilet papered yet or no no eggs dude
kids are like this Halloween last you
know that you know it was on Monday it's
like there's no Menace anymore it's like
now it's like instead of throwing eggs
at you know houses they just like jump
in front of a train or something I'm
like dude just egg my house and throw
this there's no reason to go trans and
kill yourself well I've been trying to
get one of the subway surfers to come on
the Pod like in a ski mask or something
what goes through a person's head when
they want a subway surf like genuinely
what is it like like like is it like
does the does the does the threat like
is there adrenaline rush in a near-death
experience is that what it is
I don't know it's just a way to be
gangster without hurting people besides
yourself I don't know yeah I I don't
know but would you would you if somebody
came up like and gave you a bag of
coffee like that that was Scotch tape
shut with it but you know that their
parents own a coffee place would you be
Brewing the coffee and drinking it
I have to say yes but I'll also buy
drugs from a stranger and be like yeah I
hope this is yeah I hope this is uh I
know uh uh Jasmine was like just give it
to Sergio
she goes I feel like he'll do it and
then I asked Sergio we weren't big dude
we went to SUNY Binghamton yesterday
dude I drove by the way shout out to the
kids in Binghamton the kids were awesome
they made signs they they had a the kids
in uh SUNY Binghamton were dope but it
is funny like you know like I literally
drove up there to SUNY Binghamton got
there five minutes before the show eight
uh College Pizza while Sergey was on
stage did my show got the check and got
got right back in the car and drove home
it's like sometimes like my life I'm I'm
like driving up there I'm like I know
it's good money it's it's great to get
out there but I'm like what am I doing
like what what what that that wasn't
there was no art associated with that
it's like it was pretty much like I
drove up to Binghamton got to get a
check and then hung out with the kids
for 20 minutes ate the college pizza and
drove home and
but that's like a real job that's what
that's what it is sometimes even when
you're doing creative stuff you just
feels like a real job like don't you
think like NFL players and NBA players
to them it's a day job to them playing a
game is is the day job they're like
flesh mechanics that's why they have to
do their little body stuff all the time
otherwise they suck right yeah dude and
it was one of those things last night
where I don't know if this has happened
have you ever fallen asleep at the wheel
yeah dude I fully fell asleep at the
wheel on I-95 I've watched you do that
yeah yeah I just was like I cannot stay
up and Sergio because I'm up I mean dude
like dude Violet's been my the baby's
been coughing like all night like she
stays sleeping but she's constantly
coughing and I'm like there's no way
this kid what's the baby now one she's
one uh well she's exactly she's like 15
months so interesting no no she's she's
16. about 17 months she can fully talk
now less of my she goes she goes she
says yes she'll go yes yes yes or she'll
go nice Dad out or she'll say no
um or she'll say Jerry she goes Jerry
that she points at TT sometimes she'll
say Jerry and point at me
I'm like yeah we're similar but
different
um dude TT Jerry by the way has said if
there's anybody out there on public
service announcement if there's anybody
out there who um is pregnant and it's
like unwanted he wants you to know
please don't get an abortion he wants
your baby he wants to adopt your baby TT
Jerry wants a baby and TT's asked that
anybody who doesn't want their baby that
before you abort it or give it up for
adoption to give it to Jerry Jerry's
Kids
interesting maybe we should do like a
reverse dating show or anyone who wants
to give Jerry their kids will come in
yeah and we'll see where they come from
right yeah because dude I think because
Jerry will be your mom and your dad at
the same time if Jerry was your parents
you'd probably have a good life Jared
dude Jerry loves kids she'll cook for
you
dude today I saw a TT Jerry taking down
an entire load of laundry in her right
hand and my baby in her left hand and I
was like if you fall he's like I'll
never fall she was like if I fell down
the stairs with your with Violet I would
turn my I'd kill myself on the fall
before I let even a scratch get on that
baby and I believe it I believe it no
just believe it Jerry's ride or die with
my [ __ ] kids well every time I see a
stabbing on the subway I think that like
Jerry has been on the other end yeah of
a stab yeah yeah Jerry Jerry he I know
he told me once he goes yo being stamped
hurts I was like yeah I bet yeah yeah I
didn't think it felt good and he's like
um yeah but but but you know it's
interesting I just want when he said
that to me I was like well I'm gonna let
I'm gonna let the fans at the hey babe
podcast no
um and by the way Sal's okay
everything's okay with Sally just you
know now Impractical Jokers is filming
uh again so they're we're happy that's
back and you know there's just there's
um
uh TV commitments but we are live right
now from homeless Pimp's apartment
because we were walking today and we
were like oh what's the hey babe episode
for tomorrow and then me and pimp were
like oh we didn't record one so
so we quickly I was like what kind of
guest should we get I was racking my
brain and I was like you know who the
guest is homeless pimp so why don't we
undress homeless pimp right now with
questions so pimp okay first of all how
old are you nobody knows anything about
you I know everyone thinks I'm like 20
I'm 30 30. where are you from Queens New
York okay what is your biggest fear
I don't know becoming becoming too rich
and annoying that's a fear to become
rich and annoying yeah because I used to
be a butler in the Hamptons so I hate
rich people dude you you being a butler
in the Hamptons was do you think like
what did anybody ever like what's the
worst mistreatment you got you don't
have to give a name but like in a moment
well you can give a name it's just like
you control the edit it's just like
super rich people just screaming at you
over like the forks not matching but
like legitimately like [ __ ] you've seen
a movie like screaming at the top of
their lungs in your face yeah that
you're a piece of garbage like
everyone's a prop to them they're all
very attracted to their kids like a rich
dude's always like isn't my daughter so
hot yeah I'm like I don't know what do
you want so like when Trump did it
you're like oh I've seen that behavior
oh no that's a rich guy thing Trump yeah
yeah so they would act like it's like
Trump trump stuff yeah people are mad at
Trump I'm like no Trump is every Rich
dude and yeah he just happened to get
elected yeah if you're over 10 million
dollars in in net like worth there's
something going on
yeah you almost have to be to get that
rich you almost have to kind of like
there's there's a throat or two you have
to cut to get there you don't just get
there yeah that's why it's hilarious
here Kanye complain I'm like
you destroyed everyone in your [ __ ]
path dude you think Kanye will ever come
back or you think it's over
it's over I mean would you buy Yeezys
right now if at half the price only to
like throw them in a dumpster fire or
film some kind of stupid bit you know
but here's my question okay so I have
his his player over there I'm like what
am I supposed to do with this thing
yeah look like it looked like it like it
was like a little Fleshlight and now
it's just sitting here and I'm like oh
now I have anti-semitic art isn't it
isn't it wild though that like literally
two weeks ago everything was as fine as
it could be in Kanye's life
right now
and now he said he's lost billionaire
status but I don't know he's worth 400
million right now
so pretty good yeah but how many
properties how much maintenance like 400
million goes quick when you own
Kanye as well it's one of those things
where it's like this interesting debate
with Kanye where you're like okay I get
it he should not be saying what he's
saying it's horrible what he said
obviously nobody agrees with that
anti-semitic [ __ ] we ain't about
that life on hey babe and and but on the
other hand you're like well you're
saying that he's a danger his words
Galvanize people to you know uh violence
against Jews it's like well don't all TV
shows on Netflix that have AK-47s
blowing people's heads off do the same
thing doesn't the dictator's Playbook on
Netflix do the same thing doesn't
Jeffrey Dahmer do the same thing doesn't
it all do that aren't we all just
responsible for how we act like I'm just
like at some point that argument to me
is like well what about like you just
take ownership of your own thoughts and
be like I don't I can see that this man
is mentally unwell and what he's saying
is horrible but I don't I don't agree
with it at all but that doesn't mean if
I do something negative to someone I can
get to blame it on him yeah we'll get to
blame it on anyone I think I think
nobody can tell him no nobody can say
you're stupid so we all do that we have
to do this [ __ ] because right we have to
put him in time out he's never been
putting time out if he gets back with
Kim Kardashian that would be wild he's
gonna lose his kids there's no way the
judge can be like no yeah he can have
the weekend should I send the girls to
danda Academy yeah yeah should we just
enroll secretly and film it no well it's
close they close it down oh did they
yeah yeah he's done done he's done man
well I mean dude it's it's one of those
things where life happens and here on
hey babe we just we roll with the
punches folks okay pimp and I just had a
beautiful meal pimp took me out to lunch
he got me he got me like upper class
Chipotle it's called Cava he was like
it's this great Mexican place it's my
treat and then he literally took me to
[ __ ] Chipotle that had sparkling
Seltzer Waters and like honey chicken
but it was Chipotle but dude I got to
tell you bro that was good man I took
you the homeless Soho house dude that
literally you took it yeah the homeless
house or like you know like the nice
Chipotle have you ever taken a girl on a
date there and been like you know it's
it's upper class Chipotle no no I mean I
just go to Stone Street yeah yeah just
go Stone Street's the best just get
hammered on Stone so what about your sex
life are you private with it or or do
you want to smoke some [ __ ] I mean I
told you on Chrissy chaos I had sex and
stupid roses hot dog how great is that
the hot dog costume that you guys saw on
taste buds uh with Joe DeRosa and Sal
and also if you saw if you live in the
New York area if you saw me co-host Fox
5 uh with Rosanna Scotto good day uh Fox
5 Rosanna Scotto you saw the same hot
dog costume that Homeless pimp had sex
with a girl with his girlfriend on on
Halloween night
it's Halloweeny and what better time to
open yourself up to the Unexplained and
connect your Angels or demons for
guidance and direction I know this
morning we have the person just for you
a psychic medium start with Chris first
sure my therapist says I'm very hard to
read let's see all right let's see what
you could do all right so let's see what
energy wants to give you um I want um
Latina energy oh so that's what I have
that's what I'm you know what I so this
is one of these are oracle cards so what
it is is your angel Spirits are coming
through to tell me that you need to
connect with some of your past life uh
guides so past life guides so basically
right now you're you're probably going
through some karmic lesson in your life
where you're finally now learning from
it I am sleeping in a Ramada oh that's
half thrown out last week that's true
but just know have some patience because
there's some big opportunity coming your
way and you'll be signing a contract
with that what
look at that I'm going to be the new
co-host with Rosanna
all right Pierre give me because I had
said this thing doesn't smell good and
pimp was like yeah I'm gonna tell you
why and by the way inside info just
podcast more info DeRosa was Furious
that I wore that hot dog costume because
guess what taste buds came out Monday at
11 A.M and Good Day New York on Fox 5
came out at 9 00 a.m so I beat him by an
hour and his own hot dog costume you
[ __ ] pig and then I put in finance in
it and we did the Halloween parade and
yeah find it in it that hot dog costume
we should give the fans a chance to win
that goddamn hot dog costume what what
would you do to to have that hot dog
costume it's been had it's been worn by
me DeRosa had it's uh it's got pimped
jizz in it and Ian fine dance it smoke
cigarettes on it Miss YouTube you
dressed up for hollow
Hollow Superwoman is the power of
bringing up an argument from five weeks
ago how do you feel
Wonder Woman
who gives a [ __ ]
the worst Halloween I ever had
uh I think I've had pretty good
Halloween so I haven't dressed up in
years this is the first time I've
dressed up in years
uh every time I have a girlfriend they
want to dress in like a dual costume
thing and I'm like no that's dumb and
then the night of I'm like I wish I was
more connected with my partner sir what
are you sorry for
I'm a former formal apology
Europe
that's the best costume I've seen all
night for Halloween you two are dressed
up as the scariest costume of all couple
with too much PDA
yeah
they're haunting bars at restaurants
everywhere we go
so what do you think I mean what could
people do what should we ask I mean have
people send in what like like
should we see how about this
if you'd like that hot dog costume send
us a video and tag at hey baypod
on Instagram what's our Twitter hey bay
pod as well tag at hey baypod on Twitter
and Instagram of you of you putting a
hot dog as far back in your mouth as you
possibly can and it's got by the way it
has to be a ball front a ballpark Frank
hot dog like it can't be a Vienna
sausage it do that and tag Us in it and
we'll send that hot dog costume to
whoever whatever guy girl or they be can
get it back the furthest oh that's a
good thing that's a fun contest for the
fans that's it we'll retweet them it'll
be good have your kids do it
why the hell not all right brand new
hour of stand-up material Toronto I'll
be there November 17th to the 18th
Buffalo November 19th then we got New
Year's Eve baby we got Huntington
Paramount Long Island get your New
Year's Eve tickets I'll be there two
shows in Long Island they're almost sold
out December 15 Charlotte 16th Asheville
North Carolina December 17 Charleston
South Carolina and then in January we're
in Dallas Houston and New Orleans Chris
D comedy.com for Ticky wikis brand new
hour of stand-up material I'm very proud
of it ask your friends bring your
friends thank you what's up guys big
announcement first of all the IJ tour is
going on right now the pre-sales is
going on right now uh and they go on
sale Friday morning uh which is tomorrow
morning and it is the pre-sale code is
IJ Drive we're coming to a ton of cities
so go to
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
and then come see your boy uh October
28th I'm in Richmond Virginia October
29th two in Hershey in Pennsylvania and
then the following week again we got
Knoxville November 11th two in Atlanta
on November 12th and Alabama Birmingham
November 13th everything on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com I'll see you
there dude Vladimir Putin has cancer
yeah that's Vladimir Putin of Russia has
cancer has Parkinson's and pimp I
believe you called it yeah months ago
that he's sick or that you had heard
that he was sick like because pip works
for Russia I wish I mean this whole part
of Putin's life feels like
um you know when uh when an actor when
Bill Murray's in Lost in Translation
right you know what I mean like it feels
like he's in his Golden Years where he's
a few more parts to be artsy before he
drops dude by the way speaking of movies
and TV shows I I know I went wild for
The Watcher last couple weeks I have a
new show dude the patient with Steve
Carell yeah Sal told you about it bro
Sal told me about this and I if you are
looking for Schultz on Hulu
Steve patient uh Steve Carell the
patient I've been calling it the
therapist but it's called the patient
dude the patient is dope
all I'll tell you is it opens up with
Steve Carell chained to the floor and
then it gets nuts and it's one of those
things the 95 of the show takes place in
one room
but you are on the edge of your seat
every episode and every it's one of
those shows where every time it ends I'm
like all right we can only watch one we
can only watch one I gotta get to the
gym I gotta take the kids or whatever
and then when it ends I'm like we gotta
watch one more we gotta watch one more
dude I've missed taking my daughter
Delilah off the bus twice because and
she's literally some seventh grader had
to walk up to her house and ring the
bells like you didn't pick up your kid
from the bus stop I'm like yeah well
Steve Carell might get out I'm watching
Steve dude Steve Carell is a great actor
and I've decided I've decided right here
on the hey bay podcast that I am the
next Steve Carell and I am going I'm
gonna I'm going to take acting classes
I'm gonna get on The Daily Show I'm
gonna follow Steve Carell's footsteps
because you know Steve Carell didn't
even really get in anything until he was
like almost 40. like Steve Carell was
like older he wasn't a young boy it's
just the training you have everything
else you get that training it's over I
should do it right why not Chris Pratt
blows up
yeah I'm [ __ ] Chris Pratt yeah let's
fight him that's a good match dude I
want to fight Chris Pratt
Chris Pratt all these movie stars dude
they will beat the [ __ ] out of me beat
the [ __ ] out of you they'll beat the
[ __ ] out of everybody dude I what I want
to do I I think I got a sleep test
coming up and I I'm almost hoping that I
have sleep apnea so Sal and I can do an
episode with our apnea mask on how great
would that be that would be amazing to
literally do a podcast hey babe with
sleep apnea masks on that'd be amazing
ever seen one
um I've seen Comics posts them in the
hotel like stop in the hotel with it if
you like a girl was like a beautiful
girl like you guys are about to hook up
whatever and then she threw on the sleep
apnea mask with that tutorial or that
make it more fun
yeah that's that's fun it's like Darth
Vader I like that why not yeah right
yeah
I kind of like it too man I'm kind of
hoping that I have it Jasmine says I do
she's like you legitimately she's like
you snore so loud and then you don't
breathe for about three minutes I'm like
do you try to wake me up she's like no
because I can sleep when you're not
breathing
I was like great that's her wet dream
yeah
oh my god dude but yeah man I um
I don't know I feel like um I feel like
you know that these last these last
couple of weeks I've been uh I've been
like having like these these moments
where like I don't know what it is at
the pandemic maybe it was the pandemic
where I felt like
like kind of life was over for a long
time and it was subconscious like I kind
of felt like this is the end like I'm at
the end of my life like I don't know why
I feel that way even though I'm only in
my 30s I I think it was like the
subconscious feeling like this is it
like where it kind of like it's now or
never like nothing's gonna get better
and now it's starting to clear all that
brain stuff is starting to clear where
now I'm like oh no like there's a good
chance like we all have like another 40
50 years of life like life's just
beginning it's what it feels like now
did you feel you know what I'm talking
about like that fog of like everything's
done yeah it's not like lifted it's not
like being in a tunnel yeah
like
you know everything's open people are
back but people are having full mental
breakdowns because they're not in shape
to compete anymore with each other
oh yeah that's that's why it's like
but that's why it's like weird is
because everyone's snapping because they
can't they lost their place yeah and it
almost feels like now like I went to the
gym today on Staten Island and I went at
9 30 a.m and it was packed like it was a
Saturday afternoon because people are
working but nobody's at a location
nobody's out there nobody has to be in
work right like do you feel when you're
commuting at you know 8 30 a.m in the
city it's it oh it's packed so people
are going to an office it's just not
Staten Island
I don't know I'm commuting to Staten
Island it's pretty packed on that dumb
Ferry really yeah in the morning maybe
it's just in the gyms in Staten Island
just because all those guys live with
their mom yeah I know like they never
had jobs
dude I literally I I would if we ever
got a new Killer attack and I was the
president I would put all the troops to
defend Staten Island I think you have
stat you either you have Staten Island
or you don't have a country I agree
Staten Island is one of the first places
an enemy would would see it's one of the
first places they trying to conquer if
they took over the Eastern Seaboard
you'd have to get Staten Island and
We're Not Gonna Let You
when I'm high I like to imagine that uh
the Bronx and Staten Island are flipped
what do you mean so like all the like
like imagine you just teleport all the
Bronx as it is now to Staten Island and
all of Staten Island to the Bronx that'd
be hilarious the city would be the
weirdest
yeah man uh you know Staten Island is
one of those boroughs where it's
becoming now like um like like the new
spot because people can't live anywhere
anymore so people are just starting to
be like well I guess I got to get on a
boat to go to afford an apartment now
it's a weird thing and then everyone's
like fleeing from the city and you'll
never leave though right
well I mean as as long as there's gigs
here yeah where am I gonna go where do
you where would you go really yeah see
that guy Casey whatever his name in is
nice that on YouTube no who's that uh
some famous YouTuber the fans don't know
him and he moved away from New York
saying it's over and then of course
comes right back because he's like the
content's great here yeah it's like
where are you gonna go where you can go
outside and see could anybody convince
you to not like to to leave New York to
like go work and like if somebody from
like Paris was like I want you to do
content for me here I'll give you 10
times the money could you do it
I mean depend how how old I am you know
I don't know I have friends like one of
my friends just moved to Amsterdam with
his family and started a diner really
chilling like he moved with like his
wife and kids yeah from Midtown yeah
just decided to do go he's just like
[ __ ] it
what's going on here anyway and he's
loving it yeah dude
they're like wealthy in Amsterdam I'm
like what do you do in Amsterdam dude
that actually sounds should we do the
podcast from Amsterdam I'm gonna go
visit him what I want to get some a
diner Burger in Amsterdam
I don't know probably like six months
dude I haven't had a good burger in a
long time last night I went out to the
spot in SoHo that that one famous bar
what's that remember that kid that was
going around on Halloween dressed as a
Nazi yeah did you see that yeah that kid
dressed as Nazi he went to that famous
bar I was I was there like yesterday but
how crazy is that he's dressed as a Nazi
what what bar was that
it's right in the middle of Soho uh and
and but and right by our new Christy
chaos podcast
and they have dough burgers in there oh
yeah I like getting hammered in there
it's fun yeah yeah because there's like
Rich [ __ ] in there too right or like
interesting you'll see like ASAP Rocky
walk down the street yeah you'll see I
mean that's where I photographed Joe
Jonas that's where I think our new
podcast studio is that's what we're
moving it's like not in that it's like
in that area Yeah Yeah we actually we'll
never find it we were just looking at
Studios it was hilarious Chris is
getting tortured by this [ __ ] guy
dude this guy comes up to me the real
estate agent he's like who are you are
you supposed to be somebody I know and I
was like no no I mean you listen to
podcasts then he was like he was like
asking us all these questions he was
like do you know Andrew Schultz do you
know uh who else did he say new
um do you know uh Ryan long
um then he's like all these things he's
like do you know this guy do you know
that guy he's like am I supposed to know
who you are then he goes hey it's the
your friend with the beer talking about
homeless pimp he's like is he famous too
I was like buddy nobody's gonna rent an
apartment from you if you keep acting
like this just shut up
yeah this little dog oh my God that
little dog even though I love animals I
was just I was just hoping that that
little dog's tail got stuck in the
elevator door just to just to shut this
guy up
God I mean but you know whatever I um I
like the real stage and he was a cool
dude yeah I realized so the real estate
agent who's how Wild is this we were
downtown Manhattan like three months ago
I was walking Colin Quinn you know great
comic is a good friend of mine we have
you know something once in a while we go
out for breakfast and uh Colin was
actually Colin Quinn was actually
supposed to fill in today for Sal uh
when we realized all this and he had
committed and said yes and then
immediately said no because he has to go
rehearse for his new one-man show what
was it about now damn it yeah it's like
Colin what yeah what else are we doing
um what else can you do you did you did
all the things
um and um and so
he uh uh you know three months ago it's
me and Colin Quinn were walking around
and I'm saying oh I want I want to kind
of stop doing my podcast on Staten
Island I want to go to the city and he's
like that's a stupid idea stay on Staten
Island I was like no I want to go to the
city and he goes you'll never find a
place in the city and then literally we
get stopped by this guy Connor he goes
oh I know you uh you know you guys and
he points to the both of us and Colin
was like really he goes who am I and
Connor was like I think my dad knows who
you are and then Connor was like a
condom was like you piece of [ __ ] and
then Colin goes what are you doing
Connor's like I'm a real estate agent
and he goes oh really he goes do you
show commercial space he's like that's
what I specialize in and then Colin was
like all right it's a sign and so we've
been using him
to do uh Conor to do um to rent out
spaces so uh yeah and we think we found
one and um it's dope man it's dope it's
I'm a little scared though to try you
know to because I always was like oh I
do the podcast from Staten Island I do
it from home but now it's like to leave
the island weekly it's like you're gonna
see that the the quality is going to
come up though you know what you put my
father always says what you put into it
is what you get out of it well baby
we're putting stuff into it
um and uh yeah and I think Sal's gonna
like it too maybe we'll do hey babe from
there I hope I think we should it's
gorgeous yeah I want to say I think one
day we should on hey babe we should out
of nowhere like not tell him just like
literally like start the episode and
then out of nowhere just have people run
out from all corners of the apartment
and just start tickling Sal
like just tickle them like hold him down
and tickle the [ __ ] at him and it
doesn't matter if he gets mad like we
just do it we should just release a
bunch of cats in the studio yeah and
then like wait till his face pops up and
just zoom in and out on his face
man this news cycle what do we got what
happened so boring everyone's just
attacking politics yeah the midterms
next week in whatever state you're in
and if you're not from this country you
know if you're listening from abroad the
the big midterms are happening uh next
week in this country there's a lot of
you know political races that are
very very very close like you know
states that were notoriously Republican
ago Democrat democrat or republican vice
versa and and
you know I think that the main issue is
probably crime crime in the economy
right yeah and that's all people care
about you can't help the economy at this
point what can you really do the
economy's [ __ ]
um crime is the big thing so but I don't
know I don't know you know
even crime it's like how do you help
because it's like we have a mental
health issue so it's like whether you're
Republican Democrat this that it's like
you know
yeah I don't know it's a scary time
especially New York you kind of I just I
just now anyone who looks like they're
gonna hit me I just give them a couple
bucks yeah yeah
hold on wait Tim Dillon just called me
let's see what he's doing no I don't
think I can pick up because he's calling
me twice in a row so
um
um I don't think that pause no no no no
we can't because I'm running out of time
already
um I uh uh oh dude I forgot I have to do
[ __ ]
um Fox Nation
um
Fox Nation
wants me to come on their show on Friday
but isn't that Fox's patreon
huh Fox Nation is uh fox is like is it
their patreons their premium no or is it
called live name one nation it's called
what's one nation
what is that and I just heard fox is
like a premium thing now
everyone has a [ __ ] streaming
everybody's streaming
I don't get it it's all just patreons I
know and and hey babe we waited to do a
patreon and uh and now I guess you know
everybody's doing it so we should do
something else doordash baby you know we
love it here at hey babe when you got
back to back meetings errands to run
whatever you're doing door Dash comes in
and saves the day I use it pretty much
every day I'm being genuinely honest I
think I use doordash every day or at
least you know at least five days a week
I'm using doordash you know um you know
you can get groceries you can get uh you
know food from your favorite restaurants
all national chains like Popeye's
Chipotle Cheesecake Factory all doordash
drinks snacks other household items in
under one hour
um every time you place an order for
pickup or delivery you're sending off a
chain reaction helps give back to the
people who make your neighborhood unique
um so it's good support small businesses
stores and restaurants to the Dashers
driving around each purchase provides a
new opportunity to everyone involved
because with door Dash there's a
neighborhood of good in every order I'm
telling you for a limited time all only
our listeners can get 50 off so you're
already going to use doordash now why
not get 50 off up to a twenty dollar
value and zero delivery fees zero dollar
delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code hey babe 22.
that's 50 off up to a 20 value and zero
zero dollar delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe 22 don't
forget that's code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e22 for 50 off up to a
twenty dollar value and zero dollar
delivery fees with doordash subject to
change terms apply Min mobile baby if
Ryan Reynolds is in so am I I love mint
mobile there I'm telling you so mint
mobile what it is it's a phone service
it's a premium wireless service I should
say starting at just 15 bucks a month I
thought what's the catch but after
speaking with them and using their
service which I have and they gave it to
pimp as well it all made sense there
isn't a catch folks mint mobile secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only
that's what it is okay no brick and
mortar it's all online by cutting out
the retail stores there's no crazy
overhead costs that get passed down to
you in the form of mystery fees mint
mobile is awesome I'm telling you the
quality is good the price is good and we
just pass on sweet savings to you and
you can use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts all plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network mint mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month and
if you're not 100 satisfied guess what
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee you
genuinely have nothing to lose okay the
only thing you're going to lose is not
paying more money for a phone because
mint mobile costs less and it's even
better switch to Mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com hey babe
that's mintmobile.com hey babe cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com hey babe I kind of like
doing hey babe from here I just want to
do it for me this isn't this isn't
Pimp's apartment dude Pimp's got a great
apartment Pimp's got one of those
apartments where you have to take the
elevator and then walk upstairs after
the elevator yeah it's wild dude like
this is not supposed to be an apartment
it's just you knew of somebody and they
were like we have this room but this is
dope dude this is an office so somebody
did this was an office this whole floor
I wonder who what business was here I
assume something with Wall Street I'm
not sure do you feel this apartment's
haunted do you think there's some [ __ ]
in here no man it's been cool as hell
I've enjoyed it the only thing that
sucks is when you open the windows
during October the bees come in I had
like a swarm of bees in here it was
crazy really it was crazy yeah you can't
you can't put screens up yeah I think I
was editing chaos and all of a sudden I
looked around there's wasps all over the
house do you mind now if you you guys
can't see but what he adds is is a small
apartment but cute nice feng shui but
then he's got a loft bed but it's a high
Loft like that was not made to be a
bedroom no it's like a weird two-floor
thing yeah I like to have the bed out of
the way but is there do you ever get
annoyed that you have to climb a fire
escape to get to bed or it doesn't
bother you don't bother me yeah and is
there a TV upstairs there's just the
best I don't watch TV in bed so it's
just the bed no in the middle of the
night when you have to piss or you just
like [ __ ] it I gotta come down the
stairs if I'm really have to piss that
bad yeah but do I have different times
you've just like I'd rather have you
just pissed the bed so you don't have to
come downstairs of course why not yeah
why the hell not yeah yeah I mean my the
funnest part of the apartment is my
uncle made a skull bulb Shredder toilet
paper rolls oh my God and he said that
was my gift for the house here yeah he
literally oh wow that's out of toilet
paper rolls is this the one who's deaf
yeah yeah a deaf guy made that art yeah
yeah and then there's sand in the bottle
is that supposed to be like [ __ ] he
filled up at Dunkin Donuts iced coffee
filled with sand from my favorite Beach
I think my uncle's gay
dude your uncle's gay but your uncle 's
a gay deaf guy but he's thoughtful man
how thoughtful sand from your favorite
Beach and then he just painted toilet
paper Chris you have some performances
coming up right yes I'll be in uh New
Year's Eve uh the Paramount in
Huntington Long Island my only chance to
see me uh other than only fans so which
I do in this costume yeah I I see the
thing is with me with gifts is is I just
and I know it's bad but I typically just
try to throw money at it like I'm just
like let me just buy you a nice piece of
jewelry or whatever but I know it's the
thought that counts I know it's about
being thoughtful but the problem is I
don't have any thoughts oh that's the
problem is I don't know what to do so
I'm like how about a gift card if you
got me a gift coin as a gift I would
appreciate it I don't also don't need
gifts from you ever like I don't need
you to say happy birthday I don't need a
Christmas gift it would be easier the
life would be easier if we didn't have
to buy people presents the most
stressful time in the of the year is
having to buy everyone Christmas gifts
for no reason I hate it I don't want
them by the children the gifts I want my
children to get gifts it means something
to them I get it but an adult getting a
Christmas gift
you
I hate that we have to do it I don't
want one you should want When the
Children fine if you're a chilled if
you're a child or an adult with you know
autism or down syndrome I'll buy you a
gift if you're a special needs adult or
a child you'll get a gift from me that's
what it is it is exhausting it is
exhausting and people are shitty about a
bad gift everyone's gonna get real
shitty to you yeah like even sometimes
like my mom will get mad at me if I
don't get her a good Christmas gift I'm
like Mom first of all you're the parent
you're supposed to be getting me things
like I can understand you as a parent
get like I'll get my kid stuff until
they're in their 80s like I'll get them
gifts you might have to the way dude is
there anybody who's 80 years old whose
mom and dad are still alive like could
you imagine being 80 years old and
you're still somebody's kid that has to
be people in the world that maybe like
they had their kid at like 15. and now
they're 95. yeah like it like who's the
oldest person that still has their
parents both their parents alive
interesting like right like that's like
a wild thing because sometimes you'll be
like in it's like you'll see somebody in
like their mid 60s they're like oh I'm
going to my dad's house I'm like wait
what you're a senior citizen why is your
mom and dad what are you talking about
yeah you know oldest person alive with
parents oldest person alive whose
parents are still alive that's that's
what I want to know oh God I don't want
to do this what do you have to do you're
going to go to go do one nation in the
middle of
it's like in the middle of [ __ ] it's
on like 48th Street and 6th Avenue like
there's a point it's not even about what
Fox News it's I don't care about that
because I'm just doing my own comedy
it's just like is it worth it is any of
this [ __ ] actually worth it to like have
to get in the car do the thing like
worth it once it's over
I don't know about that show I've never
heard of that show it's it's a big show
I mean Fox you know it's big but it's
like it says here Harlan Fairweather
still has one parent alive and he's 97.
he's 97. he's 97. I don't know it just
says
list of oldest people with one parent
living
yeah right right to the show right in
the YouTube comments how old are you
who's the oldest person with parents
that have parents still alive that you
know it's a it's a it's a weird one it's
an interesting thing to I mean like I'm
trying to think about like my
my mom and dad lost their parents when
they were young
as a hot dog comic I want to come up
with like hot dog catchphrases you know
like after every joke I'll be like put a
bun on it
okay so um
[Applause]
it worked did you see my catchphrase put
a bun on it they didn't like it but rule
the threes I did a second then they
loved it at the third time they didn't
like it again
we got uh dude you know what I was
thinking about the other day you know
who's gonna make a movie probably Kanye
and Mel Gibson
well Kanye's working with Andrew Tate
now so who the doesn't Andrew Tate live
in Romania
I don't think so I don't know I don't
even understand that person either yeah
I don't know what's going on dude I
don't know what's going on I kind of
just stood I'm telling you just sit back
and watch the patient and all your
problems will be watch the patient watch
The Watcher and then I heard about a
movie called
um uh uh uh uh Barbarian barbarian's
good you saw it yeah watch it it was
great on HBO or just go to theaters no
on HBO Justin Long right yeah Sal told
me do not Google anything about it don't
know a thing about it it just it ain't
just along doing comedy I heard
it made me laugh I mean we have a dark
sense of humor you might laugh but it is
would you say like a dope like one of
like the best movies
uh yeah that came out recently but it's
also a horror movie I heard for me it as
I was watching it as a director I was
like this had to be under two million
this is the best way to make money they
they printed money on the movie there's
one location
two two stars so the whole movie takes
place in one room again pretty much
right yeah and is it horror or is it
suspense or is it both it's both it's
both it's not like scare the [ __ ] at you
it's not like that other movie people
are like getting hospitalized from which
one the one that's unrated I forget the
name of it well we gotta watch it can I
watch a movie like Barbarian with
Delilah who likes horror movies I think
you could yeah all right there's one
naked lady in it but but that's all
right she's seen tits yeah he's senior
mothers this is quality tits there's a
yeah there's some fun tit stuff yeah
it's a wait I want you to I know we
don't curse much on hey bay pod but we
are all adults here what's what's a
worse word and I want you to write in
YouTube comments what word do you think
is worse it's tit like what word is like
skeevy more you think you think tits or
[ __ ] I think what's skeevier I think
the worst one is vaginal mesh vaginal
mesh is gross I think the most cringe
word of all time is feet it's a tie
between feet and phlegm
phlegm is weird beet and phlegm are
disgusting words I want them to be
canceled
feet and phlegm what about bile
's disgusting but bile doesn't bother me
as much as feet and then
ugh disgusting God so what do you have
to do the rest of the week you're doing
your Vice show dude so yeah well that's
not uh out yet I'm gonna start filming
the vice showing in December
um what do I got to do this week oh dude
I'm going to my high school 20-year High
School reunion on Saturday I like to pay
200 nice and then my boy my boy uh when
I went to high school that's like Yo
dude we should we should bring beers
into the event I was like we will get
thrown out he was like it'll be he was
like he wants to he was like oh I want
to take my wife around and show all the
places I used to sneak in and jerk off
to jerk off and I was like I'm sure
she'll love that
you have the best friend I know my my
boy was like he was like dude he was
like I was looking through the yearbook
he was like like 10 of our classmates
are dead I was like that's what happens
man it's about 20 years later yeah I
mean do you have any bits like what are
you gonna say are you going into this
what's your strategy well no they asked
me the high school reached out they're
like would you like to do a comedy skit
I was like absolutely [ __ ] not okay
no way are you gonna go to your 20 year
high school reunion do you guys go to
like our reunion's a thing you would
consider I think it's for normal people
but my high school is all like
everyone's doing heroin right most my
high school class died right and it's
all boys school so what am I gonna go
see some dudes well that's what I'm
saying I go into an all-boy school too
so it's like everyone's bringing their
girlfriends and even Jasmine's like
you're a loser for going I was like
you're my plus one she was like what do
you want me to wear I was like I want
you to look hot I want I want all the
teachers to see you and then just be
[ __ ] mad I want you to I want you to
just look hot
I don't know like it sounds awful to me
are you looking forward to seeing
everyone I feel like you had no problems
with anybody though no I don't know I I
I think like I was one of those people
where but dude you know who I hope shows
up is I you know it's a story there the
guy who uh the Cannibal Cop you heard
that he went to my high school dude so
everyone's hoping that we show that he
shows up what would you even say to him
are you hungry
I would put ketchup on my arm and be
like dude you show up in the hot dog
outfit yeah
hahaha
yeah dude no I really hope the cannibal
comp shows up
that's fun and then I got another friend
who went to my school he's like a um he
was like a professional uh like boxer
and now he's not so it'd be nice to see
him like see if he has like brain damage
and then I got like you know Patty
Finnegan Patty fly balls will be there
he's ready to go he's already pre-gaming
yeah dude he's already he said he was
like dude I'm legitimately already
[ __ ] ready to go
um
so would you what'd you think about um
elon's gonna charge eight dollars a
month for you to keep your blue check I
think Elon Musk charging eight dollars a
month to keep uh people verified on
Twitter is a great thing I want him to
charge money for Twitter and all social
media in I want him to charge 15 a month
just to have a Twitter account because
that will weed everybody out I want you
to have to pay to have that service
because then it'll become a better
platform you'll get all the trolls out
like pay to pay to play that's what I I
like it it was in a hilarious move to
make because without the blue check mark
now it's going to be kind of punk rock
why would I need the blue check mark
yeah I don't need it I kind of I come
from that school of thought where it's
like I don't need if I need the blue
check mark then I'm too big to begin I
don't even think I really have the blue
well I have the blue check mark but I
didn't like campaign like I just woke I
got Twitter because when I got on Guy
Code Twitter was kind of like a new
thing so it was like a pilot like they
just gave us blue check marks like now
oh it's like a thing right to get
verified is like a thing I remember when
I was younger it was a such a big deal
and all the young Comics were trying so
hard and it meant so much and now it's
like guys even if you have a blue check
mark You're Still to like 3 500 people
like it's still yeah there's like it
doesn't mean anything I mean I guess it
doesn't mean anything but I I don't know
social media dude I think and I think
you were telling you and I were
discussing this like you read an article
where in three to five years they think
like the youth like social media will
begin to phase out because the youth
doesn't care about it yeah right yeah
dude it's weird and you know last night
I was at some event with like high-end
production people and they talked about
how they used to photoshop the
Victoria's Secret photo shoots and
they're like we would rebuild the women
we had like body parts we could drag in
and out yeah so I'm like so this has all
been Snapchat all of this we deserve all
of it there's nothing new man it's all
it's always the same it's always the
same just different points in technology
different history it's the our brains
haven't really adapted much from 500
years ago we're still thinking the same
like you ever think about that like like
everybody was like out like everybody
was horny everybody was hungry everybody
wanted to be the biggest star in the
world 300 years ago it's just they had
different Avenues to get there just like
300 years from now they'll have
different Avenues to get there but like
the the concept of like how our brain is
mapped that doesn't change in three four
hundred years like you know like it's
just what it is man weird but what it
responds to does you know it's such a
weird yeah I think well now we're just
living in a very like open time where
like everyone's free to so I think
people might have been weirder back in
the day because they had to suppress a
lot of stuff when you suppress stuff
your brain starts to compensate in
different ways so that's why there were
more there was more wild stuff back then
because now everything's it's kind of
like it kind of sucks this world where
like you're free to do whatever you want
because it's like it like stifles
creativity it's like for me it's like
people are creative when they've got to
put them in a box and then they gotta
wiggle out of it one but it's like when
it's like hey you're free to do what you
want it's like it's kind of boring like
I don't know dude it's weird yeah like
have some real tools like like make it
like where it's like a uniform society
and everybody has to act the same way
but there's going to be one [ __ ]
that that is different where now
everybody's different it's kind of like
even different it's kind of like normal
now different this difference not
different there's no like Punk there's
so many different people
I don't know where it becomes I think
it's just gonna be I Don't Know Jack
Dorsey what's he working on what what is
this Jack Dorsey is like I'm starting my
own Twitter my own social media it's
like good luck who cares I mean I think
after only fans what can you do that's
more original
I want to start doing this podcast on
only fans
we should have not having a patreon we
have it only fans we have it only fans
it's not patreon it's an only fans yeah
that's what we have here at hey babe
why not be different that's being
different yeah we have it only fans I'm
sure they give us a deal do you think we
can get so like we'll do I'll I'll have
no shirt on and tell have no pants on
what do you think what we should do is
have have actors stand in front of a
green screen and then just green screen
your guys heads on like the most ripped
naked bodies
I think that that's the that's the move
hey babe on only fans what do you guys
think in the comment section hey babe
I'm only fans now pimp you're you're
you're the girl you're with is Latina
yes so you're are you you're becoming me
I know you have a little flag over there
look you got a little bit and a banana
you tried so hard not to become me and
now now do you guys want kids
I mean would you have a kid if you got
her pregnant right now would you keep
the child
I mean yeah you would yeah but I'm not
in a rush of a kid I'd rather chill and
see what we're gonna do for a few years
yeah but like would you raise the kid in
this apartment or would you be like I
gotta move I don't know I'll have to
figure it out right yeah does she get
mad climbing up and down this ladder
um I don't think so we gotta meet her
when are we gonna get when are when are
me and Sal gonna get to meet her you
guys well Sally's one day a month so I
don't know how that'll work I want Jazz
to meet her I want I need her to be if
we're gonna let you have a girl we she
needs to be vetted by like the like a
queen Puerto Rican I like that she needs
to co-sign the point yeah she needs to
co-sign the Puerto Rican like chat let
Jazz like sniff her out let Jess see
what's up maybe we'll make it a hidden
camera thing now does is she like is she
like Jasmine does she take her panties
off and use them as hair ties
well she's definitely going to copy
Jasmine does she have a tattoo in her
tit no uh no but there's definitely some
tattoos hanging around interesting okay
anybody Puerto Rican flag tattoos uh no
more more like hipstery tattoos I like
it dude yeah I like you're with Latinas
are the best they are I like I like I
like having Latinas I like having Latina
children I like the Latina called dude
when we went to that place for uh whose
birthday was it Jerry's birthday to
Sofrito up up in and it's amazing that
food was banging dude I want to go back
and eat food there I want to have your
next birthday there okay if I said dude
we're doing your party at Sofrito you
would do it that's in February it's
coming up right yeah let's do it Sofrito
let's do it it's booked I love it I love
it man you're all invited this is hey
babe only fans
foreign
[Music]